this is a modern day love story based in
London I usually adopters
yeah my Lane captures the beauty of when
you first meet someone and it's kind of
awkward but quite nice
[Music]
the first line in the script is posting
on Dom good looking but in an awkward
way I was like oh this is me is it
that has a curiosity about life she's
eccentric and also quite confident
refreshingly disarming David and Vivian
were amazing on their own and then we
put them in the room together and it was
just like
even though I'm capturing at a place we
all know Peckham I really wanted this
film to have its own world it kind of
feels like an adventure it's like a bit
of a wild ride through Pekka as much as
we love all those glossy rom-coms it's
not all red buses and strolls through
Hampstead Heath and we wanted to show
our version of London all these
wonderful places have been gentrified to
a degree but also still has like a real
heart and soul
we live in such a different world now
but also not everything is meant to be
political and I think there's something
wonderful about this film that it has
all those traits and all those wonderful
things that we've all been campaigning
for while also just being too young to
black people falling in love and finding
themselves but I think that's super
important people really love that
[Music]
guys
oh
[Music]